über Monate hinweg habe ich mich von
nichts zu einem Porsche 944
hochgearbeitet und das mit nur einem
Wunsch vor Augen das Auto in wenigen
Tagen zu einem absoluten Rally of Rock
Monster umzubauen ihn dann durch
Serpentin in atemberaubenden alten
Panorama zu lenken und ihn dann an
jemanden von euch zu verschenken keiner
kein GPS eine Landkarte mehrere tausend
Kilometer Straße Porsche und ich und
damit herzlich willkommen zum krönenden
Abschluss der Porsche trader-serie viel
Spaß der Alpen im Porsche 944 habe ich
gesagt nur eine Landkarte mehrere
tausend Kilometer das Auto Straße und
ich das stimmt nicht ganz den reallys
fährt man nicht alleine gerade wenn es
um Navigation geht ist ein Partner auf
dem Beifahrersitz und erlässlich und ich
könnte mir dafür niemand besseren
vorstellen als Laurenz Ei Filme Macher
Mann von Welt und absoluter Boss an der
Drohne und auch wenn ihr sein Gesicht
nicht kennt habt ihr mit Sicherheit
schon Videos von ihm gesehen
[Musik]
denn diese Videos hier kommen aus seiner
Feder bevor es jetzt aber losgeht stellt
sich die Frage welche Rallye fahre ich
überhaupt in Europa gibt es Unmengen an
Release für professionelle Fahrer für
Hobbyfahrer Baltic Sea Circle oder
einmal komplett über den Ball kam und
die 14-tägige Balkanroute wäre auch mein
absoluter Traum gewesen kann ich aber
leider nicht machen und das aus einem
einfachen Grund ich bin ein zweites Mal
an meinen spotte nach Schweden gefahren
und Seven vs wild Staffel 1 zu recreten
denn ihr wisst wie meine Leistung in
Staffel 1 war das kann ich natürlich
nicht so stehen lassen musste also noch
mal hin das kommt in den nächsten Wochen
also vergesst nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren um das nicht zu verpassen
bedeutet aber gleichzeitig wir haben
nicht genug Zeit um 14 Tage über den
Balkan zu fahren glücklicherweise
konnten wir die perfekte Rally für uns
finden namens European Mountain Summit
von Friedrichshafen an die Adria nach
Kroatien über Berge straßenpässe mit
atemberaubenden Panorama also ab nach
Friedrichshafen nicht alleine unterwegs
ich habe zwei Chaoten im Gepäck
aber Spaß beiseite ich bin natürlich
unheimlich happy wir haben Begleitung
und sehen mal wie die alte was die neue
Technik funktioniert alte Technik mit
guter Planung neue Technik mit gar
keiner Planung es wird ein bombentrip
und vor allem sind hier eine Menge
anderer krasse Autos die uns jetzt mal
gemeinsam anschauen
[Musik]
und je länger wir auf dem Parkplatz
unterwegs waren und je mehr wir mit
Leuten gesprochen haben desto klarer
wurde uns in dieser Rallye geht es nicht
primär darum als schnellster ins Ziel zu
kommen möglichst viele challenges und
möglichst viele Punkte abzusagen sondern
wirklich so kitschiges klingt dabei zu
sein und möglichst viele Pässe in genau
dem Tempo zu genießen wie man es selber
möchte und damit startet der Mountain
Summit 20 23 S65 AMG und Porsche 944
machen sich auf die Reise über die Berge
über Slowenien bis nach Kroatien von
Deutschland aus meine matt Flat
Schleifen weil wir so viel zugeladen
haben aber ich denke das sollte
funktionieren und damit ist in den fünf
Tagen Rally nicht langweilig wird und es
keine reine Punkt zu Punkt ready ist
haben sich die Veranstalter etwas
überlegt basically ist das hier dieses
Roadbook das Ding was uns komplett durch
die Tage führt zum einen gibt es jeden
Tag eine Challenge die wir am Tag
irgendwann erledigen müssen und dann
gibt es extra challenges die auf dem Weg
irgendwo zu machen sind eine extra
Straße die zu befahren ist irgendwas
extra das ist zu finden gibt Challenge
für heute Furkapass und Klausenpass
abfahren das sind zwei mörderpässe auf
dem einen hat's letzte Woche vier Meter
geschneit da müssen wir schauen
inwieweit wieder wirklich hochkommen und
damit sollte dann Tag eins geschafft
sein Digger es ist zu dunkel
[Musik]
wir sind in der Schweiz das ohne
Komplikationen ab jetzt alles dreifacher
Preis
auf Klausenpass angekommen was bedeutet
jetzt geht der Anstieg los hoffen Pass
ist offen und jetzt geht die Party ab
wir lassen also die ersten Höhenmeter
hinter uns und bringen den Porsche das
erste mal in ein Drehzahlbereich der so
richtig Spaß macht und dann sehen wir
genau das was mich zu dieser Reaktion
bringt
[Musik]
oh Digger Grad
hammergeil aber warte mal so soll das
eigentlich nicht aussehen und genau so
sehen die Aufnahmen direkt aus der
Drohne aus die eigentlich Magie passiert
nämlich abends am Computer ohne die
Programme von Adobe Creative Cloud
bleibt das Material nämlich einfach nur
blass und ist im Prinzip footage mit
verschenktem Potential besonders
kompliziert jetzt aber erst dann wenn
wir Material von unterschiedlichen
Kameras bekommen also unserem Handy der
Action Kamera unsere großen Kamera oder
der Drogen alle liefern ein komplett
unterschiedliches Bild in verschiedenen
Farbprofilen die wirklich nur schwer
zusammenpassen für uns ist es aber
unheimlich wichtig mit egal welcher
Kamera einfach draufhalten zu können in
dem Moment wo die Sachen real passiert
und glücklicherweise gibt es davon
primäre pro das Ton Mapping Tool das
alle Farben neu berechnet und zusammen
in einen und denselben Farbraum bringt
fehlt nur noch der letzte Schliff die
Musik und damit kommen wir auch zur
königsaufgabe denn die Musik kann über
das stehen und fallen eines Videos und
über den gesamten Weib bestimmt mit dem
Remix Tool von Premiere Pro erfahren wir
uns und das meine ich wenn ich sage
mühselige Hand Arbeit die einfach nur
Zeit ist Remix analysiert nämlich Songs
und findet ideale Schnittpunkte und
Loops was super Handy ist wenn Songs zum
Beispiel an gewissen Stellen vielleicht
nicht so lang sind wie wir sie
eigentlich brauchen Remix hilft dabei
den Song dann einfach ein Stückchen zu
verlängern und so perfekt passend für
unser Video zu machen wenn ihr das alles
selber mal ausprobieren wollt checkt den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
oder den angepinnten Kommentar und
probiert es einfach selber mal aus
die Einheimischen nicht verärgern nein
[Musik]
das ist mechaniker-team moin moin so
eine Rallye lebt eigentlich von dem
Motto irgendwas ist immer und wenn ich
bei einem selbst dann bei irgendeinem
der anderen Teilnehmer der am
Straßenrand steht gerissene Keilriemen
kaputte Zündkerzen überhitzte Bremsen
Motorschäden stehen so ziemlich an der
Tagesordnung ja die müssen sich die
tauschen das Auto die haben das Glück
die kommen aus der Schweiz tauschen das
Auto
gebrannt alles zu heiß geworden ist
einfach nicht aufgeben zum Glück gibt es
aber Menschen die leben in seinem
quietsch gelben alten VW Passat
tannenhelfer Rally Urgestein und ein
Gesicht dass ihr euch definitiv merken
solltet mehr dazu aber später im Video
und auch wenn uns diese Begegnung
erstmal abschreckte sollte sie uns nicht
davon abhalten den unglaublichen Pass
und die Landschaft zu genießen dafür
sollte aber eine andere Begegnung
verantwortlich sein
jawohl
meine Damen und Herren die Schweiz durch
einen Tipp vom Anwohner jetzt zu einer
Feuerstelle geleitet worden die Autos
würden sogar hier runterkommen
wahrscheinlich ne also eigentlich
könnten wir die Autos mit zur
Feuerstelle nehmen wovon wir gerade noch
nicht ausgegangen sind
wenn jetzt nicht die ersten und das Gras
ist auch noch Platz schaut euch die
Szenerie an lass mal bei Google aber
bitte gucken ob das irgendwie
eingezeichnet ist als Feuerstelle oder
sowas ist das privat oder so es wurde
uns von dem Anwohner empfohlen
da
direkt nicht zu laut haben
hier runterbringen Porsche abgestellt
zählt aufgebaut Camp aufgebaut Feuer
gemacht und den Abend mit den Jungs
genossen Tag eins ist geschafft und
scheint alles gut gelaufen zu sein das
sollte sich schon vor Beginn von Tag 2
aber noch ändern
aber mit echten starten können starten
wir erst mit unserer eigenen kleinen
challenge in die wir uns hier selber
rein mannigiert haben auf dem Weg runter
war noch alles sehr easy und jetzt
startet Hagen gerade schon seinen
zweiten versucht da irgendwie hoch zu
kommen könnte interessant werden
[Musik]
Maschine hinterher ohne Problem
funktioniert
das ganze auf und ab bringt ziemlich
viel Verschleiß mit sich und um ehrlich
zu sein mag ich Autos aber habe
natürlich relativ wenig Plan deswegen
habe ich max mal nach seiner Meinung
gefragt und das bedeutet für ihn etwas
Kopfschmerzen
viel umgebaut aber eine Sache die wir
nicht gemacht haben ist den Zug
Mechanismus der Motorhaube zu reparieren
deswegen muss ich hier mit der Zange
jetzt schauen wir mit Mechaniker Max und
Hagen
Arsch Alter
das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal auf
eine gute Technik schließen müssen
schon abgebrochen ist mit so einem Mann
nix gut abenteuerlich also drauf 200 ml
drauf und
[Musik]
und damit
endet Etappe zwei Tag zwei im Hotel
morgen heißt es wieder draußen pennen
morgen große Etappe und heute war
einfach ein absoluter freestyle-tag und
ich muss sagen das war obwohl oder
vielleicht weil wir keine Challenge
gemacht haben bisher der absolute
Traumtag ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
und Stopp willkommen im wunderschönen
Hotel Arsch und damit Tag 3:3 von wo
auch immer wir sind bis nach Bozen wo
wir uns mit allen anderen Reli
Teilnehmern auf einem Berg soweit ich
weiß treffen und schauen wie viele von
denen noch übrig sind wir wissen ja es
gab Motorschäden es gab diverse andere
Pannen und mit absoluter Sicherheit der
nicht alle Leute die gestartet sind auch
in Bozen ankommen wir hoffen dass wir
ankommen und wir hoffen dass wir eine
richtig schöne Fahrt haben ihr müsst
euch vorstellen wir sind jetzt noch
nicht mal bei der Hälfte Strecke
angekommen der gesamten Rallye und wir
sind schon knapp 1000 km über
irgendwelche Landstraße und kleinen
Ortschaften Gefahren Handbremse raus und
los geht's
wir rollen den Stelvio Pass an nachdem
wir gerade schon eine unheimlich schöne
Berg Überfahrt hatten und in der ersten
Kurve offenbaren sich zwei Autos aus der
Rallye die wir schon beim Start
kennengelernt haben nachdem wir jetzt
über 1000 km irgendwo durch Dörfer
gefahren sind tauchen diese beiden Autos
auf und jetzt fahren wir im Kolonne den
Stelvio Pass richtig richtig geil
als ich geil
richtig geil
[Musik]
ich habe unendlichen Kilometer an
Alpenpanorama Schnee und dem krassesten
Pass zwischen Schweiz und Italien war es
soweit wir sollten unser Tagesziel
erreichen und dass wir eins der letzten
Autos waren das beim Checkpoint
eingetroffen ist war wie die Tage davor
auch überhaupt nicht schlimm wir haben
uns darauf konzentriert uns eine gute
Zeit zu machen in unserem eigenen Tempo
zu fahren Pausen zu machen und die Zeit
ist wirklich zu genießen Tag hier ein
besonderer Tag und vermutlich mein
Highlight darin so das erste Mal wir
sind am Blöcken passt gerade das erste
Mal wirklich
in die Mangel nehmen können jetzt ist
auch der Zeitpunkt gekommen wo ich
probieren kann das Heck war ein bisschen
das Heck zu grüßen
hier links geht's richtig ordentlich
runter wir müssen schauen dass wir
langsam genug sind dass wir in diesem
coolen wie hier nicht aufsetzen aber
noch genug Power haben um danach die
Berge weiter hochzukommen
endlich sind wir mit dem Auto in dem
Terrain für dass wir es gedacht haben
und es macht richtig Laune
[Musik]
wollte eben mal die Grenzen
das Aktionen wie diese gut gehen hat
auch immer etwas mit Glück zu tun eine
falsche Bodenwelle eine Stein der aus
dem Boden guckt den man übersehen hat
irgendwas reißt auf und die Rally ist
damit beendet oder man ruft Hardy an ja
ich bin
Helfer ich mache das in meiner Freizeit
in meinem Urlaub ich habe irgendwann mal
eine Leidenschaft dafür entwickelt das
auf den Rallys zu machen ich liebe alte
Autos und fahre hier die Rallys mit um
an den alten Autos zu schrauben weil
wenn du so eine relige gebucht hast
gibt's eine Menge Geld aus am Ende ist
es so ich Filme die Pannen die ich mache
ich dann damit mit Handy rum mit mit
Kamera Filme das ganze weil ich
irgendwie festgestellt habe dass das
irgendwie den ein oder anderen
interessiert dass das lustig findet dass
das spannend findet ich sag mal im
Schnitt ist es prorelli guck mal wenn
ich jetzt 15 17 Release gefahren bin war
das vielleicht 300 Leute 400 Leute die
nicht helfen konnte wovon gute 60 70 vom
Ausfall gerettet wurden und das finde
ich so das ist so für mich das spannende
je länger wir gesprochen haben desto
mehr ist mir aufgefallen wie viele
unglaubliche Geschichten bisher auf
solchen Rallys schon passiert sind also
habe ich einfach mit der Kamera weiter
drauf erhalten und alles festgehalten
damit ihr am Ende aber nicht zwei
Stunden interviewt sondern nur die
besten Parts bekommt gibt es die
textbasierte Bearbeitung ein Tool so
einfach wie genial mit nur einem Klick
sagen wir dem Tool welches Video im
Hintergrund transkribiert werden soll
und nur wenige Augenblicke später haben
wir jedes einzelne Wort das gesprochen
wurde in einem Quelltext in einer Liste
in diesem Text können wir dann easy nach
Schlagworten oder sogar ganzen Sätzen
suchen und diese Parts dann in die
Timeline ziehen oder sogar löschen wenn
wir sie gar nicht brauchen checkt also
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
oder den Link im angepinnten Kommentaren
wenn ihr als Schüler und Studenten 65%
auf euer Creative Cloud Abo sparen
möchtet um eure Videos aufs nächste
Level zu bringen oder eines der
unzähligen Tools von Adobe ausprobieren
möchtet also vielen Dank an fürs möglich
machen dieses Videos und euch viel Spaß
weiter mit der Rand nach dem kleinen
Offroad Spaß ging es dann aber wieder
auf befestigten Straßen weiter
übernachtet haben wir in Felgen am
Wörthersee sollte jedem von euch sein
der irgendwas mit Autos zu tun hat oder
sich dafür interessiert haben uns eine
schöne Nacht mit ein paar Drinks im
Casino gemacht schön für mich nicht aus
aber es war trotzdem ein schöner Abend
[Musik]
das Auto hat tatsächlich durchgehalten
ihr merkt wir waren wirklich platt aber
nach tausend Kilometer dann auf Straßen
Schotterpisten und mehreren Nächten im
Zelt sollte es etwas zu feiern
das war's wir haben es geschafft wir
haben es gemeinsam geschafft Laurenz und
ich als Fahrer mit diesem Auto und es
hat eine Menge Spaß gemacht ich finde
das war ein gebührendes Ende für Trader
Staffel 2 Unmengen Stunden vor dem
Rechner vor der Kamera im Schnitt haben
zu zwölf Videos dieser Reihe geführt ich
bin unendlich dankbar für euren Support
und will hier auch noch mal kurz sagen
trade ab Staffel 3 ist schon in Planung
und wir lassen die Köpfe auch vielen
Dank an alle Partner die das in
irgendeiner Weise möglich gemacht haben
vielen Dank für euren Support und ganz
speziell vielen Dank an der Dobby fürs
möglich machen dieses Videos wir sehen
uns in den nächsten Wochen wieder zu
seven vs white dem zweiten Versuch an
meinem Spot vergessen also nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren macht's gut ciao